Biden first got in I'm like the
probability and chances of us going
towards high now 100 in Ukraine and it's
been absolutely true now you know this
leads us to kind of question is it
because he's a bad leader is it because
he's a failed leader is it because he's
an incompetent leader or is this a part
of a bigger ruse a bigger plan in order
to bring something else in that will of
course profit and benefit off of these
problems that are being deliberately
caused right now it could be both
because I do think he is incompetent
well based on the Afghanistan surrender
that is the most incompetent use of the
American Military I've ever heard of to
lose that war that we are winning to
give up to the Taliban and let them take
over like that I I gotta disagree with
you I think that was an act of pure
competence it was intentional you do not
accidentally abandon an Air Force Base
in the middle of the night that can't be
an accident no it's one thing it was
intentional which